Jang Jong from USC and he'll talk to us
about streaming lower bounds
for uh thanks Jan for introduction uh
today I will talk about uh streaming
lower bouns for the needle proper uh
okay so uh this Bas uh this talk based
on to join works one is with join work
with shahal and the other one is a join
work with ch and Shan uh okay so uh in
this talk I will cover four parts at the
first I will introduce what is the
needle prop and then I will talk about
some lower bounds and then I will also
uh give two uh proofs so because we have
two joint works so basically two proofs
okay so let's get started with the
needle problem this problem is a pretty
simple problem I mean the statement is
very simple so we consider two
distributions one is just a uniform
distribution over a large domain yeah by
the way if you have any question feel
free to stop me uh okay so the first one
is the uniform distribution uh so the
second one is just we first the sample
needle we sample element we call the
needle uh in this distribution from this
from this domain sorry uh sample X and
then we sample uh many uh samples uh so
such that equals x with probability p
and the uniform otherwise so there are
two distributions and the goal is going
to distinguish them okay so the question
is that given bounded uh memory so how
many samples do we need to distinguish
these two
distributions that is the question I
hope it's clear yeah if I have any
question to
[Applause]
ask so are we
good okay so let me
first what should I think of PS uh p is
just a paramet something between
constants and square root n yeah if it
is is much smaller than square root n
then probably you are really hard one
divided by sare sorry yeah okay uh so
let's discuss some simple algorithms so
that everybody can have a sense about
the problem so the first setting is that
okay without any restriction about space
you can use whatever you want of the
space so then we have a most
straightforward aru just Resto restore
all of the samples right so just put
everything in the memory and just count
the most frequent element so of course
this will be a the needle if you have
enough samples by simple probabilistic
calculation you know that whenever you
have more than one divided by P samples
then you can check you can find the fre
uh the needle with high probability and
uh yeah and the space you this is a
straightforward algorithm need to cost
log n divided by P space because for
each sample you need log n space and so
you have one divided by P samples okay
so this is the first setting the second
setting is that I have a really really
strong small space so really really
small means you have a probably log n
all the log n space so then another
straightforward algorithm is probably
just okay we just take all the samples
and then remove and and remove them and
only keep the most recent the two
samples whenever you see uh two
identical elements in the I mean two
conec uh identical elements then you say
okay so this is probably the needle so
in this thing if we do a calculation
know that you need oneid by P Square
samples with this amount of samples then
with good probability you you can find
two consective identical elements and in
this setting we only use order and all
log and
space in both settings and so for
General space se you can extend a
general tradeoff between these two
algorithms so whenever we have s space
so basically we just restore the most
store most the recent roughly s number
of samples according to your calculation
then you need roughly T is divided by
log n divided by S * TP s samples so in
all of these tradeoffs so the the
tradeoff here is that whenever you have
I space then your sample is roughly log
n divided by P S 10 P
space okay so the question is that
yeah all right so what about this
algorithm that you focus on whether this
needle is the element one and you read
at most like P like one over P elements
like Logan over p and if you if the
needle is not that one you move to the
next one and next you don't know the
needle yeah that's why you are iterating
over all possible choices of needle what
does that give you so so there is an
algorithm that use order log in a space
you assume the needle is the first one
yes you need login over P samples to
decide whether that's correct or but how
about if this is the not the then you
move to the next element yeah yeah yeah
so okay so this is a good algorithm but
I'm not sure what is the test base for
this one we can do a probab
probabilistic calculation yeah but my
main focus today is I want to show this
almost the
tight yeah yeah yeah so you can do
whatever smart algorithm I want to show
no matter how smart you are this is
roughly the tight F got it actually
there is a non algorithm so it's able to
remove the log and factors here so yeah
so the best
algorithm the optimum algor known today
is that the trade off is T is roughly
one divided by SP
squ okay so yeah actually so my next
question is whether this is tight okay
so basically we prove this is tight so
this is our uh results so uh so we we
showed that whenever you want to
distinguish this distribution with
constant probability then you need one
divid by P S * P Square samples and also
for we can General it's for any L pass
algorithms multi pass three algorithms
so basically you just multiply another L
by
here
okay okay uh okay so so why we studed
this question yeah actually I I was not
sure why should we study this question
when now even we Pro that this result
yeah because this is a byproduct of of
of our communication complexity result
so after we have this result we ask
somebody ask David asking whether this
is important okay so they to David told
us okay so basically give some
applications so it's somehow important
okay so the one of the applications is
that in the frequency estimation setting
so I think a frequency estimation is
really important problem in streaming
algorithms so uh so basically you want
to estimate the uh frequency
uh frequency moments of a data stream uh
okay so but I won't spend too much time
on here so as a corollary so we can show
that for every if you want to estimate
case moment frequency moments so you
need Omega and the oneide one minus 2K
space yeah and so for the previous best
no result was given by Adon uh m m g on
and penr Fe is the the one the one minus
2.5 divided by case of
Base I just to ask so throughout this
talk all your bounds that you state
you're you're implicitly making the
assumption that P is at least one over
root n is that correct yes yes yes yes
that probably answers seer's question as
well because one over p^ squ is better
than n over P which is
what okay
sure uh okay so yeah so we improved this
uh here yeah and then also this is the
the random order setting of The
Frequency estimation so all of the
samples account from a random order not
the adversary
[Applause]
order okay so then we are talking about
the how could we prove this lower bounds
uh okay so in order to prove this lower
bound actually so yeah as I said this is
a byproduct of our communication
complexity results so so we we spend a
lot of time to study communic uh uh
disjoint this probably in a
communication complexity so the D
problem is also can be stated simply so
basically you have a k k person K party
each person each K players each person
uh has a set SI and so we promise you
that either of these siis of the sets
are disjointed or there is a uni
intersection unit intersection means
there is a one common element which uh
belongs to all of the set and for every
two pairs the intersections of these two
pair of this set is exactly X so by
removing the common elements so all the
rest that is joint okay so the
communication complexity problem is that
we want to distinguish these two distrib
uh these two case uh these two cases and
so this is a very important result from
communication complexity is that the
randomized the communication
complexity uh is roughly the summation
of the size I divided by K and this is
also pretty tight by a Prett tight to a
simple uper bound algorithm so let's go
back to this problem so if you want to
design the algorithm so what is the most
intuitive way to construct the algorithm
to uh construct the communication
protocol to distinguish these two
cases s yeah yeah yeah so the smallest
SI just going to say okay so this is my
set the the the player I which has the
set SI with a smallest size and going to
tell everybody else okay so this is my
set I right so the cost is is roughly
the lens the size of II Times log n
because each II
has is an element of n so basically this
is uh this okay so this is the most
straightforward uh
uh sorry okay so this is the uh
straightforward upper bound algorithm so
if all of these I I almost the same size
so basically they'll uh reach the lower
bounds by up to a log Factor so are you
in the Blackboard model or message okay
so it's just everybody can BR I think
it's broad custom model everybody can
talk to everybody else yeah and the
lower bound is a really strong lower
bound because this a really uh strong
model
yeah okay so how it connects to the
needle problem okay let me give you a
really really simple explanation and I
think this is uh is very intuitive okay
so let's imagine that's in the data
streaming setting so because we have
probability P to get us needle so in
expectation they're roughly P * T
needles right okay and so let's consider
a simple case okay so let let me just
try to uh re uh just the partition the
data the streaming samples so we have t
samples we just cut it'll by uh cut into
uh P * T parts so each parts has roughly
one divided by P samples so basically
the first the one divided by P samples
this is the second one divided by P
samples and bl I just going to cut them
and shape reshape them in this way looks
like a matrix and each row has one
divided by P samples let me tell you a
very simp let's starty with a very
simple case is that I promise you that
each row has exactly one
needle so then how how Okay so this a
very simple case right uh so then how
can it be connected to the U streaming
uh needle proper so basically whenever
we have this communication complex lower
bound how could we convert this lower
bounds into the streaming lower bounds
so basically the idea is going to use
the communication protocol to simulate
the streaming algorithm right so then we
can make a connections between them okay
so how could we use this communication
complexity to simulate any argm
a
so basically let's we have two settings
one is the streaming algorithm so now we
want to simulate by communication
protocol I the communication the
simulation is pretty simple so the first
player get the set SI meaning the first
row the first player get the first row
and I'm just going to re audit run the
audit and I simulated this algorithm
with the first ice elements right first
this elements I simulated this algorithm
and I'm going to pass the the memory at
memory information at this point pass
this information to the second player
and the second player gets this
information M1 right and simulate
continue
simulation and all the way to the end
just the last player so the last player
is able to finish off the simulation and
output the output with a so basically I
just partition the data and a streaming
data and send it to each players and
each player simulate one by one so this
a oneway protocol very simple
communication protocol and to what is
the total communication complexity here
is K T ice why uh k k is just the number
of players right K is number of the
players and each players send ice bits
to the next player because ice is the
space limitation the space size of the
algorithm so the so the information of
the the lens of M1 is at the most s so
basically the total communication is a k
time
[Applause]
size
okay so the total communication is K
times ice and the communication lower
bound is uh from the communication uh
lower bounds we know that uh this is at
least uh Omega the summation of this SI
size divided by K and also the size of
Omega divided by K the number of players
and recall there are the relationship if
you because we partition the T samples
into uh T divided by P players so
basically K * p is equal to T yeah and
so by combining everything together we
know s * T is equal to oneid p^
[Applause]
squ so but this is a very simple case
the the issue is that we are not that
lucky to have a a a symmetric partition
such that each part has exact exctly One
play uh needle so if we record the
calculation whenever we have constant
space whenever we see one divided by P
Square samples then with high
probability we'll see two consecutive
needles so it means you can it's really
hard to partition equally so that it
means whenever T is much larger than one
divided by P with high probability you
will see two needles in the same part so
this probability really high so if you
do a uh probability calculation we know
that two with high probability there are
two needles with distance one divided by
P Square * T so whenever T is much
larger than
n sorry T is much larger than one
divided by P then you'll see two needles
are really close to each other so this
partition is really hard so therefore we
are not able to have first find such a
good nice partition so this is the main
difficulty of this
problem okay
so any questions so
far
fast just to understand
your so you are saying if you were lucky
and the input like if we fix the
partitioning and each player got one
then it's that destroy us yes yeah but
now you want to fix the stream and pick
the partitioning afterwards yes so we
have to do unmetric partition so
symmetric partition okay so this is
symmetric partition right call symmetric
because each part has exactly one divid
P yeah so therefore we have to partition
in a unsymmetrical way got it yeah yeah
so this is the main difficulty and yeah
and also we also need to change the
problem of the communication problem
because that was the because whenever
the the difficult so the Harden so we we
we have a low Bound for the
communication problem right and the
harder instance that is that all the set
I size has almost equal size so that
reach the typ lower Bound for the
communication problem so yeah but
whenever so as uh as we discussed
whenever I I a different has a different
size so there is a one guy we can which
has the smallest set as like always just
broadcast this person's set so the
communication overall communication
complexity is really small whenever
direct exist which is really tiny right
so therefore we need an an symmetric
version of communication complexity yeah
this is the main
difficulty okay so what is the
asymmetric version of the data uh of the
communication complexity problem is that
okay so let's let's study a more general
setting yeah so if if all the set SI has
the size at most SII now I promise you
that uh the the sites uh the K players
again there are K players each has a set
as side and I promise you that each set
SI has size at most small SII now we
want to uh determine whether there are
uh correct we want to determine whether
there parse D joints or has a unic
intersection
okay so let me go back here okay so now
for this question we have a another
upper bound is that the the s i we we
clearly know the the upper bound should
be at at most the log n times the
smallest I side right because the
smallest St I just telling everybody
okay so my my set is really small and
this my set okay so and we can also
prove the lower bond is also Omega SI
where SI is the smallest size but that
is not enough so that but this is not
enough for the uh for the asymmetric
version because in in the needle problem
we know there are some pair which have
constant size whenever T is roughly has
one P Square for example right so there
could be some SI is really tiny so
therefore we need a really good an
symmetric ver of this jointedness so
basically this is proved by Shah and I
so we proved that the Shar lower Bound
for the an symmetric version has defa
for is the summation of the The Ice part
is communication complexity divided by
Si is equal to Omega one so if you go
back to the symmetrical version so all
of the I size has the almost the size so
basically the summation of Sigma I is
dra just roughly the the size of side
divided by
K okay so this is the sharp version of
the UNM of disjointedness and so yeah as
I said our our Lev bound is byproduct of
the communication complexity problem we
first have this low bound and then we
ask then we found application of
these this I qu a byproduct so we first
have this one
okay
any so basically whenever we have this
this one we use this communication uh we
use the the instance of this
communication complexity to simulate uh
the original streaming uh the the needle
distributions so therefore we are able
to
achieve uh a tight uh almost a tile
bound so basically we use the how hard
the distribution of this uh
communication protocol to simulate
original uh streaming needle uh original
needle distributions so basically we are
able to get T this low B is roughly T is
Omega 1id by s p sare log n samples it
almost match the the tide bound except
uh the extra L and factors and Shaha and
I spend a lot of time we're trying to do
a different simulation different
uh uh decomposition of the distributions
to remove the log and Factor however we
still we we were not able to remove
these log and factors by Under This
approach
okay yeah I going okay any
question okay so yeah but I'm not going
to spend too much time about this proof
because I want to switch to the second
proof which is the title gives the title
of without this Lo effect by using a
different
proof okay so the second proof is that
information
complexity uh information complexity
based uh approach so this is this is so
the reason this get the title bound is
that we without using the blackbox
reduction to the streaming uh to the
communication complexity problem so yeah
I call it a white box but but I still
call it a white box reduction so because
the idea of proving uh un unique
disjointed this low bound is by using uh
one one of the nice proof is based on
information complexity but now we are
not going to use the communication Pro
uh prod to do the reduction but we going
to adap the information complexity
notion directly so we use the
information complexity to prove the low
bount directly without using the
reduction from the
disjointness so yeah this gives a P
bound okay so let me recall the uh
needle distribution the need needle
problem is that we want to distinguish
these two distributions so d0 and d0 is
the uniform distribution D1 is the
distribution minut 18 minutes yeah it's
much faster than I have expected yeah
but we have more time to discuss okay so
the need distribution is that one need
and each sample get a which equals x
with P okay so let me introduce another
distribution which is called the local
needle distribution the local needle
distribution is just a combinate is
something between uniform and needle
distribution is that I first fix a set s
okay so and so for uh for each uh sorry
first the fixed a and so for all of
those uh uh for all of this uh so sorry
we have say we have t samples right we
have t samples we first set fix I is a
subset of this T So fix some locations
so now basically the idea is to fixing
these locations and this is the
locations this is the only locations
which possibly have the needle so for so
the so formally so we for each uh data
streaming sample so uh if this this
location is in Ace so we Pro outut the
needle is probably p and all of the rest
are uniformly
rented
so just be clear when you say s are the
only locations where you can have the
needle you could have them you could
have him in the other locations if he's
uniformly picked yes uniform so
basically this is the for a fixed ice so
basically we decompose the1 to a
combination of D IES yeah this is the
idea thanks for this question yeah so
technically this is the same as picking
a set of size roughly PS fixing the
needle but obviously for the proof not
going be different yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you guys get the point so this is
my next slid Okay so so we consider IES
to be roughly 2 * P * ice constants this
size right so we first this set which is
the we call candidate no needles the
potential position to be needle and so
it so in the set I so roughly half of
the needle just by expectation right so
in expectation we have P * D needles so
we basically first sample set is which
is double the size and so we call this
potential needle and so half of the
needles and we can actually we can
compose the distribution D1 into uh the
summation of this AIS so we just set
like first sample so we have two steps
of sampling first the sample a then
sample needle real needle yeah candidate
of needle and needle okay so now by
using average argument so basically we
can show that whenever d a is able to
distinguish d0o and D1 then it can
distinguish uh d0 and DS for many s so
this basically this is follows by just
the average argument because we can
decompose D1 into this fors and by
average argument so for enough DS we for
enough ice we can uh
distinguish d0 and D1 well and so now
the last step we want to show the
information cost I Define what is the
information cost very soon but just have
this in your mind so the information
cost of distinguish DS and d0 is Omega
one so we I first going to restrict the
small set I going this is only all the
potential
know so even even after this restriction
so you still need Omega one cost
information cost to distinguish DS and
d0o so this is the this is the proof
strategy okay and the last step we just
because for many ds so from this step we
know we know a can distinguish many ds
and d0o and for each Ace such that if a
can distinguish then you have omega one
cost and so then the overall cost we
want to argue that one divided by P
Square so because each local s you have
some cost Omega one and so have many s
you can distinguish them I combine them
together so this is one this is pro
[Music]
strategy
sorry
that that glass board obviously follow
from the preceding bullet or is that
part of the thing you're going to prove
it's not it's not obviously is is
follows by truth and also one of the
really crucial thing so this this looks
uh straightforward but one of the really
crucial thing is going to how to define
the information cost information
complexity it's a really you really need
to find a really really good definition
otherwise we be we cannot prove the tile
B okay thanks yeah yeah
yeah I think the main difficulty in the
previous approach was not successed is
because in previous approaches there
wasn't such there wasn't such a nice
information cost yeah okay so let me uh
introduce the information complexity so
uh uh okay so actually we used the sorry
I forget to site the year is 2020 so
that's the reason I say the previous
approach does not have such a nice
information cost this was introduced by
2020 okay so this is the information
cost by uh braan gar and UD okay so this
is for U for one pass uh one pass
streaming algorithms okay so it it
defines in in this way so mi here I
referred to the memory so mi mi means
the memory status after receiving the I
sample and I K is the case sample I are
samples and this is the memory
status okay so they Define in this way I
was going explain the intu very soon
okay
um Kus one
yeah so M K minus one means the messages
up until until here I'm k k is the so
this is so there are two summations so
the first is the summations from I to T
this is the summation of the samples and
this K just a summation from I to uh one
to I so I are whom the players or the
like
the the times in the yeah both of the
times of the receiving the samples so M
of is that M of minus I what is m K
minus I'm K so K minus one is the Kus
one
sample okay so okay so sorry let me head
here is that you have uh
X1 isn't just State yeah after the
receiving I yeah Kus one is the memory
receiving K minus one got it
yeah okay oh and K minus one is less
than I yeah Kus one is less than I oh I
see so it's the information the first K
minus one play you condition on that Mi
is someone way into the future yeah yeah
Mi is something in the future and XK is
yeah is something after this status
after K minus one so this condition K
minus one right this is the sample next
to this one and this is in future okay
so so the confusing thing is that Mi
there are M there things from MK minus
one to Mi yes that will determine
combined with XK all of them will
determine M yes okay and you're ignoring
those yeah yeah I just yeah I just come
sound okay and so yeah this is a really
carefully designed thing so it's not
that is very is a very elegant design
okay so yeah and so we can show that
whenever the samples as long as the
samples are independent so we have we
can show the i the information the up
bound of this information cost is p * s
okay so this is not a very true trivial
thing if you just Why by using the very
very trivial upper bound say this is
something like uh log n right because
this information is uper bounded by the
lens of X I log n and the summation is T
Square so if by using a trivial
upperbound so you get something T square
but the The crucial thing here is T
times ice so yeah so this very carefully
designed but the proof is
straightforward by some by information
the calculations but this design very
carefully I'm I'm going to show this
part okay so yeah okay now now let me
introduce the local information
complexity okay local information
complexity this one is really reveals
how the intuition so okay so let's say
we have set ice so the potential can
potential needles we fix ice and we
Define the loal local information
complexity related to s in the following
way is
that uh we have some needles right
probably I can draw it
here okay let's say this is
P1 this is
P2 this is p Pi for example this is pi
and this is Pi +
one okay only these positions could be
uh needles so for each I if we fix I
okay if we fix uh I so this part is that
with summation of okay so this is
probably this is PK right PK for
example okay so we fixed
the uh we fixed the the the memory
States here condition on the memory
State here and I calculate the mutual
entropy of the this guy this this memory
State
uh calculate the mutual entropy of PK
this PK Mutual entropy of
K and and the mutual entropy of this
memory status the memory here and the
mopy of PK so the intuition is that okay
so Pi I + one could be a needle right is
a potentially to be a needle pi plus one
potential to needle in order to detect
the needle so in this location you must
store sound needle information from some
information about the previous needles
otherwise in at this moment you can
never know this is a needle right this
is the potential needle but in order to
detect this needle in here you must
remember something about the previous
needles you must remember something so
therefore this is the summation of all
things here we summation all of the
needles here and for each eye we
submission all the needles
and and for each needle we submission
all the previous needles and what is the
mutual entropy of the previous needles
and the the the space before
MK so basically this is the local uh
information complexity and this I think
this one is more intuitive right so this
one very intuitive okay so yeah so
therefore we uh so we show that uh LMA
is that if we want to show a distinguish
d0o and D DS then this must be Omega one
so you must remember something Omega one
because you you if you want to achieve
constant probabil distinguishing
probability 0.1 then probably overall
you need to restore some omega one
information okay so and the
the the surprising thing is that how
could we get a one divided by P Square
actually this is by a simple calculation
expectation calculation so how could we
show the the Global Information
complexity is uh oneid by B Square Times
the expectation of the local information
complexity is that in the for is that is
because for each for each turn right
here what is the probability fix say fix
I and the K so what is the probability
that uh this
uh probability over Rand s over Rand s
what is the probability that this turn
will be chosen to the local information
cost so it is oneid P Square why because
it is chosen to the is the local needle
information complexity local complexity
information on if and only if both K and
I sorry both I minus one or both K minus
one and I are chosen to be in the set
s here so both these two things are
chosen to be in the set s so because the
set of s is roughly P times T so each
element is in s with probability oneid P
or we get one P Square this is how we
get this the the mag iCal number oneid
by P squ so just by expectation so the
probability both of these two are being
as one b square you have two items so
therefore we get this bridge so this
bridge make this
connections and so the last step is
going okay so the last step is going to
the information complexity this is Omega
one so in order to prove this is Omega
one this is
this is a we still use the something
from from communication complexity so
but we we use the communication
complexity is going to say each set I I
has set has set most constant so if you
go back to the original communication
complexity problem is that each party
has a set SII now we reduce the case
that each SI has size at most Constanta
one so yeah because you fix the side as
side so this side has Omega one and the
good thing that now you want you you a
our goal is just going to prove Omega
one communication complexity Omega one
so this part become easy so after this
partition I mean this DEC composition
TOS so this part be we can use the
follow just by previous communication
[Applause]
complexity okay so basically by using
this idea we prove this is the the title
bound T is equal to 1/ S p² and this can
also be extended to the multipass
setting the multipath setting is by uh
using a new new notion of multipass
information complexity yeah yeah again
in this communication in this notion is
only designed for one pass but in order
to extend to multipass we we must
carefully design and generalize a new
version of this information complexity
yeah after this new version I think this
the the multipass multipass
generalization is is our main
contribution in our this work so we
extended the uh extended to multi pass
notion and therefore we can get the
market pass tight Bound for all Ts and L
okay so this is our main
result I'm almost finished yeah thank
[Applause]
you quite a bit of time for
questions
okay um so for the for the multipass
extension does it also give a lower
Bound for the multipath version of the
coin problem uh coin problem so there
are many coin problem it depends
on oh I mean the the coin problem that
was studied in the yeah bgw paper okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so um okay
so yeah probably I I can say it for now
yeah so we we have a discussion with
these three authors and they uh they
also have uh yeah they also have their
notion of multipass you VAR recent I'm
published paper and they used to prove
this T bank and we have discussion about
what is the relations between our
multipass that there multipass and the
conclusion is that they're
incomparable yeah but I think so but the
thing that yeah overall my feeling is
that it really depends on the specific
problem so we designed in a same high
level high level way we design
conditional we we smartly choose
something to design to condition here so
this is both our spirits to design
multipass but there we we condition on
different things because we studed
different problems so overall I think it
could be depend on problem but we in the
same framework so basically condition on
something but different things yeah yeah
they have a un published
work any other questions
yeah but by there are there are some
followup works so for example there the
paper by uh BR B and Smith they prove
they use this notion to prove some uh
learning problem no bounds and so it was
in code 2022 and we we checked that with
with with high probability that our
notion can be extended to the uh their
code paper results yeah
do you believe that uh the
infrastructure you're using here for the
um upper and lower bounds can generalize
to a problem where there are more than
one needles like a two or three needle
problem yes yes this is a really good
question there there's another extreme
case Okay so think about so there
there's another question which is one to
one versus one so there are two
screamings one is that uh all of the
elements are distinct distinct so the
other one is that there are many pairs
so each element appears twice but in a
random order so there are over two
elements so this is one two one versus 2
to1 and there there's also a a reduction
so there's also reduction published in
Euro recoup 2018 so basically they show
the a low Bound for data setting but
they also have an extra log and fact
loss so there that is also based on
reduction to un disjointedness and they
also have a l and gap of the upper bound
and lower bound so what we are trying to
do now trying to okay so could we use
the information complexity to remove the
look and Factor again so for that
problem so I think there are many
possibilities
here thank you
[Applause]
thanks
questions do you have any idea on what
would be the correct one for p smaller
than one/ squ uh for p smaller than one
square root N I think for uh data
setting I think
we we with some chance we cannot recover
them yeah with bounded space yeah so
when p is much smaller square if you
have unbounded space yeah yeah I don't
know so for instance algorithm let sayir
it gets n over P so if you have any idea
on
what uh so for the UN so we always uh
for unbounded space I think probably
something you can do is just remember
all the thing and check what the most
frequent one and we found the space um I
think this is a really good question and
so in in the in in this case all things
this must be very carefully calculated
because in here for example everything
here just Omega one but when in a region
that the parameter really really tiny so
the dependency over here is really
important what is the accuracy parameter
and so what is the corresponding there
there could be some dependency such like
the accuracy is Epsilon and this is EP
square that that part even be be very
carefully calculated in thata region so
in here we just hide everything Omega
one so everything is fine yeah thank
[Applause]
you
question question suppose I want to
distinguish between a heavy needle and a
light needle so I want to distinguish
between p and p over two yes um I think
the communication argument don't go
through right in that case and does the
information uh argument go through uh
okay so the communication Yeah we
actually so I'm not going to say the the
communication that's not going through
because because you say it does not go
through because just you applied the
original uni disjointness lower bounds
but you can such like our asymmetric
version probably there is a different
version of disjointedness still make it
through so disjoint there the huge
number of variant of disjointedness
there might be some of them make it go
through but information complexity I
think I agree this is the most
straightforward way most straightforward
way I think there a chance it go
[Applause]
yeah that made me think of a different
question
um what happens if you don't know P
because there is there a strategy that's
better than just guessing uh if we don't
know P okay so do you mean uper b side
right or the lower bot side the lower
bot side let's say we're guaranteed it's
big enough but we don't know what it is
okay so uh I think the um I think it
does not affect the algorithm so the
algorithm we never use the information
of B we just have the inform the idea is
just going to do store the space until
it it fulfilled whenever it is full then
we just remove the first one we just a
window sliding out we never use the
knowledge of P so the upper B also goes
through right yeah and the lower B also
goes through because the calculation
here yeah it only makes this problem
harder so therefore the lower bound also
holds
[Applause]
okay speaker once
more